[Musique]
une orthographe fantaisiste faire passer
un jeune homme est un message clair
cessé de provoquer les pickpockets
pas vu pas pris l'image d'un fantômas du
réseau irrésistiblement attiré par les
poches béantes des voyageurs une
campagne clin d'oeil avec le tutoiement
de rigueur pour la complicité la ratp
dans son désir d'informer de mettre en
garde fournit même quelques exemples des
différentes manières d'opérer
regardez cet homme dans quelques
instants
des manipulateurs chevronnés dont le
subtiliser son portefeuille
cachée par le journal la mince avance
saisie en douceur
repli le journal le tour est joué
les pickpockets sont souvent des
monsieur tout le monde n'ayez donc pas
de préjugés le coût du sac maintenant
une femme absorber et négligente
la tentation est grande le carnet de
chèque a changé de propriétaire
consignes à respecter
pas de sac ni de poches ouvertes
ayez l'air sûr de vous les principales
victimes étant souvent les personnes
âgées les femmes et les touristes
mais vous pouvez aussi être la proie
d'une bande organisée comme ce brave
contrôleurs
monsieur je pourrais de la salle
omnisports
pén demandes de renseignements un
complice s'approche l'objet a déjà
changé de mains le troisième larron
s'éloigne 280 agents de la sécurité et
policiers ont incontestablement un effet
dissuasif mais pour réprimer il faudrait
constater flagrant délit c'est
pratiquement impossible 4000 vols à la
tire ont lieu chaque année dans le métro
pour casser ce marché la ratp espère
rendre la vie impossible aux malandrins
dans le domaine du vol à la tire c'est
beaucoup plus un problème de prévention
qu'un problème de répression
surtout lorsque le délinquant et ta
petite année ce sont les bandes
d'enfants et je pense qu'une un certain
type de comportement une certaine
attitude des parisiens des habitants de
la région ile de france par rapport à ce
phénomène vaut beaucoup mieux
une multiplication abusive de présence
policière dans le métro ou ailleurs des
affiches aussi dans les rues bientôt
fantômas pointera peut-être au chômage
la dernière campagne contre la fraude
avait bien marché le nombre de fraudeurs
auraient diminué de 15%
[Musique]